N
SISTERS.
DOZENS OF OTHERS WERE HURT.
INCLUDING A BABY.
HUMAN REMAINS FOUND IN THE
DEBRIS OF THE TITAN SUBMERSIBLE
RECOVER BEFORE THE ATLANTIC
THERE'S STAY.
INVESTIGATORS HOPE THE CAUSE OF
THE CATASTROPHIC IMPLOSION
WHICH KILLED ALL FIVE PEOPLE ON
BOARD.
CNN'S PAULA NEWTON HAS MORE
DETAILS.
>> U.S. COAST GUARD ANNOUNCED
THAT IT HAD FOUND WHAT IT
PRESUMED TO BE HUMAN REMAINS ON
THE SEA FLOOR.
THAT WOULD BE FROM THE
SUBMERSIBLE TITAN.
THEY RECOVERED THE REMAINS.
SAYING THAT THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WILL CONDUCT A
FORMAL ANALYSIS.
OF THE PRESUMED HUMAN REMAINS.
AND OF COURSE THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS OF THOSE FIVE
PASSENGERS WHO DIED ON THE
TITAN WILL BE COMPLETED BY THIS
BUT ALSO FEEL AGAIN PROFOUND
GRIEF.
GIVEN WHAT THE U.S. COAST GUARD
SAYS WAS AN IMPLOSION OF THE
TITAN.
SOME ORIGINAL.
WHAT IS ALSO HAPPENING NOW IS
THAT ON WEDNESDAY, THE HORIZON
ARCTIC RETRIEVED DEBRIS.
IN FACT LARGE PIECES OF DEBRIS.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE FINISHED
THEIR WORK OUT THERE.
AT THE SITE OF THE TITANIC
WRECK.
AND WHAT IS EXTRAORDINARY HERE
IS THAT THEY DID IN FACT
RECOVER LARGE PIECES OF THE
DEBRIS.
YOU COULD SEE THE TWO WHO.
I HAD A GOOD CHUNK OF THE
PASSENGER FRAME.
AGAIN THAT ISSUE HERE IS THE
CARBON FIBER MATERIAL.
USED TO HOLD THE PASSENGERS.
USED IN THIS KIND OF DEEP SEA
EXPLORATION.
U.S. COAST GUARD SAYS THEY WILL
BEGIN TO EXAMINE ALL BUT.
AND AGAIN THERE ARE MANY
INVESTIGATIONS UNDERWAY.
INCLUDING HERE IN CANADA.
THE INVESTIGATION EXPECTED TO
TAKE WELL VERY.
FORMER ASSISTANT SECRETARY
SECURITY NOW TEACHES AT HARVARD
UNIVERSITY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
RIGHT NOW, IT IS STILL NOT
KNOWN HOW MUCH THE TITAN
ACTUALLY, CAUSE THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT HAS APPARENTLY
WORKING ON THAT NUMBER, BUT
CANADA SENT MORE ASSETS INTO
THE SEARCH, FRANCE WAS INVOLVED
AS WELL.
AS AN INDICATION OF THE COST,
IS PART OF A REPORT FROM THE
WASHINGTON POST.
THREE C-17 CARGO PLANES FILLED
WITH EQUIPMENT FROM BUFFALO TO
STAGING POINTS IN NEWFOUNDLAND.
THOSE FLIGHTS COST AN ESTIMATED
$491,000 ROUND TRIP.
SO, YOU, KNOW THAT WOULD SEEM
TO BE A TINY FRACTION OF THE
COST HERE.
SO IN TERMS OF RESOURCES COME
INTO THE SEARCH, HOW MUCH IT IS
GOING TO END UP COSTING AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT?
>> IT IS GOING TO BE MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN THE LOW NUMBERS
AROUND MILLION THAT WE
INITIALLY HEARD, YOU JUST THINK
OF MAN OR WOMAN, POWER TONIGHT,
OF ESSENTIALLY A WEEKLONG
EFFORT, YOU ARE GOING TO GET
LARGE NUMBERS.
AND, THIS QUESTION OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE SEARCH AND
RESCUE, IT'S DIFFERENT I.
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR, IT IS
DIFFERENT THAN SHOULD THERE
HAVE BEEN A RESCUE.
ABSOLUTELY, AND INTERNATIONAL
CONVENTIONS, WE HONOR
INTERNATIONAL SEARCH AND RESCUE
CONVENTIONS, EVERY COUNTRY HAS
AN OBLIGATION TO HELP A VESSEL
THAT IS UNDER THE STRESS.
SO, FOR SOME PERIOD OF, TIME
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN AN
ASSUMPTION THAT THEY COULD HAVE
EITHER SURVIVED, OR THAT THE
SUBMARINE WAS FLOATING AND THEY
COULD JUST FIND IT, AND SAVE
PEOPLE.
ESSENTIALLY, OVERTIME, THOUGH
THAT BECAME CLEAR IT WAS NOT
THE FACT, AND THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE RESOURCES THAT WENT TO AN
INCIDENT THAT WE CALL A
DISASTER MANAGEMENT LOW
PROBABILITY, AND ESSENTIAL LOW
CONSEQUENCE, RAISES A CONCERN
THAT THOSE RESOURCES WERE SPENT
BECAUSE NOT BECAUSE OF THE SORT
OF RESCUE, BUT BECAUSE OF WHO
WAS IN IT, AND THE PUBLIC
PRESSURE TO DO SOMETHING.
>> WELL, PENTAGON SPOKESMAN --
WHO WAS ASKED ABOUT THE COST OF
THE TITANS SEARCH LAST, WEEK
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO THINGS LIKE
OPERATING AIRCRAFT, THOSE COME
FROM APPROPRIATED FUNDS WHICH
ARE ALREADY BUDGETED SO, THOSE
ARE HOURS THAT ALREADY HAVE
BEEN PAID.
>> YOU, KNOW THE COST MAY HAVE
ALSTILL HAD TO COME FROM
SOMEWHERE, JUST BECAUSE IT'S IN
THE, BUDGET DOESN'T MEAN US
FREE.
>> EXACTLY.
LOOK, I MEAN, AN EXPENDITURE OF
FUNDS IN ONE PLACE IS GOING TO
TAKE AWAY EVENTUALLY FUNDS FROM
ANOTHER PLACE.
SO, EITHER WE SHOULD OWN UP TO
THE AMOUNT THAT WAS SPENT, AND
HAVE A REASON FOR WHY THAT MUCH
MONEY WAS SPENT, OR BEGIN TO
HAVE AN HONEST DISCUSSION ABOUT
RISK, AND PROBABILITY, AND IF
YOU NECESSITATE TO DEPLOY OUR
SEARCH AND RESCUE RESOURCES,
WHETHER IT IS A SUBMARINE, OR A
HOLD OUT ON AN ISLAND WHO WON'T
EVACUATE DURING A HURRICANE, OR
HIKERS WHO ARE CARELESS AND
THREATENED FORCE RESPONDERS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE SAVED,
ALL OF THOSE ARE HARD
QUESTIONS.
BUT THEY ARE ONE OF THE
DISASTER MANAGEMENT COMMUNITY
IS ASKING RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE I
THINK WE HAVE --
ONE HAS TO SUSPECTED THIS QUITE
HIGH.
>> AND, AGAIN JUST DISTRESSED,
THIS IS NOT ABOUT YOU KNOW NOT
HELPING PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DISTRESS, BUT WHAT MAKES THIS
CONTRAST SO GREAT, IS THAT
WHILE THE WORLD WAS FIXATED ON
THE SEARCH FOR THE TITANS
SUMMER SUPPLE, AND FIVE VERY
WEALTHY PEOPLE IN THEIR, THE
NEW YORK TIMES HAD THIS
HEADLINE, FIVE DEATH AT SEA
GRIP THE, WORLD HUNDREDS OF
OTHERS GOT A SHRUG.
AND THOSE OTHERS WERE THE 750
MIGRANTS WHO DIED WHEN A BOAT
CAPSIZED IN GREECE.
AND A POINT LOST ON FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
HERE HE IS.
>> RIGHT NOW WE HAVE 24-HOUR
COVERAGE, AND I UNDERSTAND IT A
THIS SUBMARINE, THE SUBMERSIBLE,
AT THE SAME TIME RIGHT HERE IN
JUST OFF THE COAST OF GREECE,
WE HAVE 700 PEOPLE DEAD.
>> WHAT MAKES IT EVEN WORSE IS
THAT THEY'RE GREEK RECRUITS
GUARD DID NOT OFFER --
UNTIL IT WAS WAY TOO LATE, AND
IT COMES DOWN REALLY TO A
QUESTION OF PRIORITIES.
RIGHT?
>> IT DOES, AND WHAT THE CREEK
COAST GUARD DID WAS NOT PURSUE
TO THEIR OWN OBLIGATIONS, MORAL,
OBLIGATIONS BUT ALSO TO ALL
COAST GUARD ARE, UNDER WHICH IS,
IF A VESSEL IS IN DISTRESS, YOU
DO NOT ASK QUESTIONS, IT DOES
NOT MATTER WHAT THEY WERE DOING,
OR WHERE THEY WERE GOING, OR
WHETHER IT WAS LAWFUL OR, NOT
IT IS A COMMUNITY OF RESPONSE
EFFORTS THAT ALL AGREE THAT A
SHIP UNDER DISTRESS SHOULD BE
SAVED, AS YOU, SAID IT DOES NOT
GET TO THE MAGNITUDE, AND I
THINK WHAT THE SUBMARINE WITH
THE TITAN, WE CONFLATED HIGH
INTEREST WITH HIGH CONSEQUENCE.
IN OTHER, WORDS THIS IDEA THAT
THE SUBMARINE HAD A BIGGER
STORY THEN UNFORTUNATELY PEOPLE
--
THE WORLD, WE CAN SEE WHY IT
HAD BILLIONAIRES, THE TITANIC,
AND ALL OF OUR FEARS OF GETTING
CAUGHT SOMEWHERE WITH THE
CONSCIOUSNESS OF DEATH, I GET
IT, BUT IT DOES NOT EXPLAIN THE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES THAT WERE
SPENT TO FIND A VESSEL THAT
EVEN IF HAD BEEN FOUND, IT WAS
NOT AT ALL CLEAR HOW WE WERE
GOING TO GET IT TO SURFACE.
>> AND AGAIN, OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
A TRAGIC ACCIDENT, VERY SAD FOR